Cody's been on a sex show binge like
[ __ ] the box was it enough he had to
go see another one in Amsterdam because
that's what it's known for bro I mean
like you go to the red-light district
it's like hookers and windows and then
it's sex shows now I disagree the moment
said the moment Matt said floor covered
in [ __ ] I was like nah that place that
place is weird hoes decided to go to
that place last time so that's why I
don't wanted it and that it described
when we were walking by and I was like
yeah I have to [ __ ] listen put two
euros in and just see what the [ __ ]
they're talking about cuz it's like so
there's like this famous sex show place
with a giant pig on the front and then
right next to it is basically like a
Peep Show
so you walk in super famous place I
guess yeah it's it's like a circle of
booths all looking into the same area
and there's a spinning bed in that area
so you walk into one of the booths and
you can only fit two people max in one
of the booths so you can go in as like a
couple or they just tell you to go in it
by yourself and you put money into the
coin thing and it unfought the window so
then you can see the show in the middle
and you can see across to another booth
right and that's the sickest thing is
that you can see the other people that
are watching so we were like that okay
let's just at least like go in and just
put the feed the meter and see what the
[ __ ] is happening in there right
thinking that it would be some some [ __ ]
that people would pay for you know right
and it was I mean it was not what did
you get we walk in there feed it window
on fogs and it's this girl lying on her
back like this with her leg up and this
dude on his knees naked eating her out
neither of them we're into it she was
like basically essentially on her phone
but without her phone she's just like
looking off like trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] she could entertain
herself with he was just soft as baby
[ __ ] uh we should damn I didn't want him
to have a boner but at least like it'd
be nice to know if he was into it you
know like that would make the show
better if he had a hard [ __ ]
it would add to the ambiance a it will
make the vibe a little bit okay well
clearly doing their thing greater I said
it was like they don't want here either
so just it made it feel even more sick
yeah cuz not even his biological switch
could kick in they're not like not even
the [ __ ] will to hunt nothing it was
just a guy with a mouth on a vagina
chewing on it like a jawbreaker yeah
yeah just waiting for that moment II can
clock out I'd have been so depressed
walk the [ __ ] out it was that's what we
did yes we're like this sucks I'm and if
I'm being real that's the thing like
like the way like the girls in the red
booths like look through you or like are
on their phone it's not to say they
don't enjoy what they do but you can't
deny some of them don't they don't come
across as like they're super stoked to
be there cuz I feel like it just becomes
a job at a point yeah totally so but
it's like it's but it's also like they
don't really have to be into it like no
that's fair there's enough foot traffic
there we're like they just stand there I
know that's like somebody will come in
eventually but at that point it's like
you're just working in a sperm bank
you don't know saying he's got dudes
coming through just jerking them off
with a condom and a [ __ ] babe on
their dick you know how many people do
you think are like in it for the passion
yeah it's let's see yeah that's true
better no what I'm saying is some people
like really enjoy it no that's that's
fine but what I'm saying is like for
them I feel like it's the same as like
working at Hooters but instead of
serving chicken wings they got a jerk a
dude off with a look and latex glove
yeah so all I imagine is like they're
saying hi how many yeah one second
suh-weet okay yeah we have a table for
two all right right this way okay and
they're like oh oh all this place my
favorite she's like yeah please just
just separate just room one room - we
should leave her our number on the bill
sir please just have a seat thank you
I'll be there in a moment and then she
[ __ ] she's so hot dude
gloves goes in the room lays down the
boo cuz there's the thing it's not like
a sexy time in there no no yeah it's
[ __ ] medical as far be know yeah this
[ __ ] she's just like in [ __ ]
Medical
cabinets yeah it's like all white walls
yeah yeah okay any allergies oh no I can
I could pretty much handle anything
latex yeah maybe you should go wrong
with the hands oh yeah haven't heard
yeah dude I want to know for them like
when a retail person pulls out a hundred
dollar bill and goes hey just printed it
myself yeah I want to know their
equivalent yeah yeah yeah a [ __ ] awful
joke they hear every custom my god so
true it's probably it's probably like
you know lerczak to latex yeah some
[ __ ] or like bigger than you thought
huh yeah some weird [ __ ] about like less
awkward yeah all the [ __ ] out some of
the biggest one today no you're not and
just lay back please no eye contact
uh looper no Lube sir alrighty the most
like it's like a factory this one I mean
you walk down that [ __ ] yeah they're
just standing there but it did dip
inside yeah they close the [ __ ]
curtain yeah like it doesn't depress me
because it's a sex job that look like
when I would work with guys that had
that [ __ ] thousand-yard stare though
they've been in the office too long that
[ __ ] makes me die inside I can't explain
it so when I see a person at their job
like just wanting to [ __ ] quit I'm
like yeah it's also like it's
interesting like how here you know they
do that here they it's like it's like
multi level [ __ ] structures that you
go into yeah and at least episode I've
heard I've never been to one
no yeah but it's like isn't it that like
cuz what I would see is like dudes
popping out of random doors so like
because of the way the buildings are
structured I assumed it's like like they
go in you go in and then that you're you
do it you do what you want but in
Amsterdam it's like you're seen by
everyone oh that part of it yeah yeah
sorry I thought you mean like when they
leave no I just meant like do people
come out of that same door yeah it's
like you go in you come out I thought it
was like because it's like a house I
thought it's like connected to like a
front door so I thought like you would
just like get kicked out that
in Amsterdam yeah oh I don't know I
don't know I just assumed you go in you
come out see dudes coming out of the
door with their hoods up and they come
on boys ain't no way yeah you walking
out that [ __ ] you just walk it all her
up like it's some guy hey Dave yeah well
[ __ ] did you know that they're there for
a working offense Michael yeah Michael
what do you think about the meeting
today you didn't just go in there did
you was clean
Michael further Michael you did not
Michael
I went in that one earlier today how
good was it amazing nothing like it I
think I didn't even know [ __ ] could
happen with two hands good happen she
was nice enough she'd like made it like
a little little pepper grinder if it
were the nice in there
you